republican senator rob portman of ohio
is the ranking member of the senate
homeland security committee and he was
at yesterday's hearing he joins us now
from capitol hill senator good morning
to you so much to get to
let's start simple after hearing what
you heard yesterday how are you feeling
this morning about the breach
well i think we've got big problems in
two ways one we weren't properly
prepared
that goes to the intelligence failure
you just talked about and you said it
exactly right there was
plenty of other evidence though in
addition to the fbi report that never
reached the right people there was
evidence
in the public media as an example that
there would be violence
and then second our police officers were
not properly trained and were not
properly equipped
they had not been trained on
infiltration they did not have riot gear
as compared to as an example the
metropolitan police department at the
in the district of columbia that have
that kind of equipment and training
and then finally after the attack
occurred
why did it take so long uh to get
reinforcements there particularly
national guard
yeah and as you say there are
differences of opinion there we're going
to get to the bottom of it we have to
because it's so important
this never happens again yeah it sure is
senator after 9 11 i
recall people pointed to a lack of
coordination between law enforcement
agencies and intelligence groups
now 20 years later it seems like a lack
of coordination was again an
issue would you agree absolutely the
norfolk office of the fbi provided a
report to the joint terrorism task force
we know that
that report then came to the capitol
hill police but it got stuck in their
intelligence division
uh at the level of a sergeant never got
up to the decision makers
that's a problem and that's part of what
you're pointing out continues to be a
problem that
the intelligence is out there but it
often doesn't get to the right people in
a timely manner
if it had i think they would have been
much better prepared including calling
in the national guard to help
and frankly you know being better
prepared not to have the perimeter be so
far out to be able to you know
anticipate what was going to happen
and yet they did not have that that
intelligence and and they weren't
prepared again
i will say there was a lot of
information out there that this was
likely to be a violent encounter so
i don't think that the intelligence
report uh not being there uh
excuses the fact that they weren't
better prepared yeah well hindsight is
always 20 20 as we know yet there is the
question as you point out of why we
didn't see this coming in the first
place
something that's been raised and i want
to put to you now is
was the nature of the threat something
that blinded law enforcement in other
words this was not a foreign terror
group
at issue here but in fact white
supporters of the sitting president
what we heard yesterday was that there
had been a couple of other maga rallies
that had occurred
and that law enforcement i think pretty
much across the board was looking at
that as the model
that was not the model this was very
different and again this goes to
intelligence to know that
those previous demonstrations although
there had been some violence associated
with them
usually after the demonstration as i
understand it usually on the street
relatively small numbers of people
this was different in kind and again
looking at the
information that was on the web both the
dark web and on the open web
that information should have been able
to be extracted and it was different in
kind
senator there was a moment yesterday
where your fellow senator ron johnson of
wisconsin
raised a conspiracy theory about who in
fact was assaulting the capital
suggesting
it was fake trump supporters given what
we know isn't it dangerous for
a republican to continue to lift
up false information like that
yeah the person who was quoted said
things that are entirely counter to what
i know to be true from law enforcement
by the way both in classified and
unclassified settings
so i i don't think that's helpful i mean
i think the the reality is
that we had intelligence as to what was
going to happen uh we knew some of the
groups that were
likely to be involved uh oath keepers
proud boys and so on and that you know
that was
um that was not just evident in terms of
the intelligence but also when you look
at the arrests that were actually made
recall there have been about 200 arrests
yeah we know who these individuals are
so we have to be sure that we're
sticking to the facts yeah
senator you voted to acquit president
trump in charges that he incited
the riot the insurrection there but you
also said there's a possibility that he
could face criminal charges and so i
want to ask you
when he reappears sunday as he's
scheduled to do at a major republican or
conservative
conference how do you feel about that do
you want him
to continue to be the very public leader
and face of the republican party well i
think he will be tony
because he's got a high approval among
republicans
and you know we we as the party uh have
to focus in my view
on the policies and the ideals that you
know frankly in the 2020 election
um others did quite well we picked up 15
seats in the house as i understand it
uh we did better than expected in the in
the senate races uh we did better in
terms of state house picked up the three
additional states
in terms of their republican majorities
in their state houses so
when you stick to the policies and the
ideals of the party including
some of the issues regarding the economy
which was going quite well prior to
covet 19
and kind of get back to the basics i
think that's what we ought to be as a
party
it shouldn't be about personality it
shouldn't be about one individual it
should be about who we stand for as a
party
all right senator rob portman thank you
very much we appreciate it